Hunter Biden has a new ally his legal
team is now teaming up with January 6
committee investigator and former
Republican Congressman Denver riggleman
now not content with the LIE of Russia
manipulation the wriggleman is Shifting
the goal posts we want to look at first
is the data that's out there that's
purported to be Hunter Biden's laptop we
wanted to see if there was any forensic
format or any forensic
validity to it and there was none I am
shocked that anybody in congress would
use that data or any journalists would
even use those sources because what we
found out and we we do have the data and
we have specific instances of
fabrication and manipulation of the data
so what I would warn Congress and warn
any journalists out there is that the
data that's in the public sphere right
now has no relation to any forensic copy
that's attached to a hunter Biden laptop
can you believe he was actually in
Congress joining me now is a Powerhouse
Duo house Judiciary Committee chair Jim
Jordan and house oversight committee
chair James Comer Congress and Jordan
let's start with you your response to
what your former colleague is alleging
now about the laptop
well I mean if it's not Hunter Biden's
laptop why doesn't he say so I mean
that'd be the first thing I would do I
say that's not my laptop why didn't the
Biden family just say it's not my laptop
they've never said that because it is
his laptop and anyone with common sense
and and any bit of reason and logic can
see that so they've never that'd be the
first thing I would do frankly so you
know everything we hear from these guys
just turns out to be something you can't
really believe I mean for example why
won't the White House tell us that it
wasn't the Biden that had the cocaine at
the Y I mean on and on it goes with
these folks so I mean that is just
ridiculous that Mr riggleman would would
come forward with that argument I will
tell you this Gary shapley 14-year
veteran handled the biggest tax fraud
cases International tax fraud cases he
sure seems credible to me uh you're
gonna take his word or the word of you
know riggleman or whoever else is
talking
now Congressman calmer um the wiggle man
also commented on the IRS whistleblowers
seems like a lot of the other so-called
whistleblowers I don't know if you want
to Define them as that it seems like
they're always wrong either you know
Witnesses turn up missing or dead or
somehow the data just disappears into
the Twilight either these individuals
the whistleblowers haven't been trained
properly
um they're credulous right credulous
idiots other Liars or their grifters or
some combination of all that above
Congressman Comer your response
he should be ashamed for trying to
discredit what's up Lord we want
whistleblowers to come forward Democrats
used to want whistleblowers to come
forward Ritalin is what CNN and the
other liberal Mediapolis love he's a
disgruntled Republican that they can get
on their TV show to trash other
Republicans look as Jim Jordan said that
laptop is Hunter Biden CBS did a
forensic audit to prove that these
whistleblowers are credible they've
never had a blemish in their records and
everything they testified under oath uh
during their transcribed interview in
ways it means to be we've been able to
back up with bank records in our
investigation
well Congressman Jordan according to uh
this new report from Fox News digital
uh nearly a dozen current and former
officials serving in the White House in
the bite Administration including the
president's National Security adviser
and Secretary of State have extensive
ties
to Hunter Biden now Congressman Jordan
Hunter isn't just some like wayward son
who you know has struggles with drugs
he's an operator and he's making
connections because those connections
pay off big time
big time sure you know they sure do as
as chairman Comer and and the oversight
committee has uncovered 20 some
different companies millions of dollars
being funneled through each of these
companies paid out to multiple members
of the family it sure does pay off so
but again the one thing you always look
at is what were they doing what was the
service they were providing what were
they getting paid for so you know you
can believe what you're hearing from
that side or you can believe Gary
shapley who came forward and the other
whistleblower who's remained Anonymous
who's come forward as chairman Comer
just indicated their stories seem to be
stacking up even against the U.S
attorney I might the U.S attorney said
oh he was able to get special counsel
status if he wanted it Gary shapley says
the opposite the U.S attorney Mr Weiss
says he could bring the charges anywhere
he wanted Central District of California
District of the Columbia Gary Shepley
says the opposite someone's not being
honest here someone's not being
straightforward and again I go back to
Mr shapley seems very very credible he
sure does I watched that interview did
on Special Report and I mean it I I was
blown away by what he said now
Congressman Comer today uh in the U.S
attorney's office for the southern
district of New York they announced
charges against gal Luft who claims to
have provided the FBI with information
on the Biden family's business dealings
in China he says he's not a Republican
or a Democrat he was just concerned
about a potential president of the
United States having such
um incredible conflicts or perhaps be
compromised so Congressman Comer your
reaction to the timing of that
indictment
the timing is always uh coincidental
according to the Democrats at the
Department of Justice look here's what I
know about Gala he was getting paid like
the bidens from cefc we want to speak
with everyone that we can find who was
also on the payroll of cefc like the
bidens and anyone who says we shouldn't
take Godless allegations seriously
discounts the fact that the bideners
wanted to share office space with cefc
even going so far it's the same they
wanted that hunter wanted to make an
extra set of keys for both Joe Biden Joe
Biden and the president's brother Jim
Biden so this company that Gallup was
working for who he was getting paid for
is the same company that the volumes not
only were getting paid for they were
also sharing office space with so we
definitely want to hear more about these
allegations and we want to see the notes
from the FBI meeting they sent six FBI
agents according to Gallup to Brussels
to interview him I mean obviously they
were concerned about something he had to
say they're so level of credibility
there so there are a lot of questions
here and it's just amazing the
Department of Justice moved so quickly
against some people but then a lot of
the ultimate irony is one of the charges
they levied against he was not being a
Richard foreign agent which is the main
thing that we've said the bidens were
all about unregistered foreign agents
well
um Congressman Jordan Congress Jordan
Congressman Comer thank you both for
being here tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else